[Music]
another great way to stay motivated and
compare yourself to other linkers is by
joining challenges
to start a new challenge click here
here are the active challenges in french
i can complete the 90 day challenge by
earning enough coins to meet the coins
target
i earn coins by adding known words
creating links and learning them
i can check the leaderboard regularly to
see how i'm doing compared to other
linkers
or just check my progress against the
coins target
i can also see a challenge summary in
the weekly report email
there are other challenges
like the hardcore 90-day challenge which
is well more hardcore
to complete this challenge i need to
complete the targets shown for a variety
of activities
and the requirements change as my level
increases
the monthly linking challenge involves
creating as many links as i can in a
month
i can earn a badge for my profile
250 gets me a bronze badge
500 silver
and 1000 links in a month will get me a
shiny gold badge
this leaderboard shows how many links
other challenges have made so far
and of course i'm automatically enrolled
in the 1000 word challenge in every
language i start
sign up for a link challenge and see if
you can make a breakthrough in your
language
happy linking